donc à partir de
2006 Farid berama est tué par des Corses
sur une affaire de machine à sous et là
c'est 10 12 liottenant vont s'entretuer
jusqu'en 2010 et ils vont se rendre
compte qu'en fait c'est compliqué de
tenir les cités c'est-à-dire d'avoir une
gestion pyramidale être avoir un chef et
toute une hiérarchie en dessous toute
une série de personnes qui qui va
jusqu'au gateur jusqu'aux petites mains
qui va gérer une cité c'est là qui se
rend compte que il faut il faut voir les
choses autrement et ils prennent
finalement le pli de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans l'économie légale ils
vont ubériser le trafic de su ça va se
faire sur 5 6 ans ça va pas se faire
d'un coup ça démarre doucement en 2010
ça se met vraiment en place en 2016 et
ça s'est accéléré en 2019 avec le le
confinement c'est très simple on a des
grossistes qui sont du trafic
international qui sont des héritiers de
la frenche ou des héritiers de grand
banditisme à travers l'Europe hein ou à
travers le monde qui vont être importés
sur la France France sur l'Europe nous
ce qui nous intéresse sur la France des
immenses quantités de drogue
principalement par conttainur assez peu
par gas le gofas c'est pour amuser la
télé he en fait il y en a très peu par
rapport au quantités astronomique arrive
tout simplement dans les containurs et
généralement c'est tout simple à
Marseille c'est un exemple c'est pas
uniquement Marseille à porintou Duon
arrive par jour 350 conttaineurs de
charbon de bois depuis l'Afrique de
l'Ouest en Afrique de l'Ouest on a une
mafia Corse implantée puissante et qui
entre autres activités fait aussi dans
la drogue et qui va récupérer par
exemple de la cocaïne et va l'importer
via le Gabon par exemple ça peut être
l'Angola pour d'autres mafias jusqu'à
Marseille ou d'autres villes comme comme
tous les ports en gros tous les port
d'Europe mais Marseille c'est ce qui moi
me me concerne et cette drogue là est
vendue à des GR SEM donc ça c'est les
grossistes il vont être vendu à des semi
grossistes donc ce qu'on appelle souvent
les dealers les chefs de réseau ils sont
chefs de rien du tout ils sont unique
ceigrossist ils ont quelques hommes avec
eux ils récupèrent ce cette tonne là par
exemple et ils vont la distribuer sur
des cités donc ça se fait ça se déroule
souvent dans des dans des petites villes
autour de Marseille donc grognac Gignac
vitrol les zones gendarmerie puis qu'il
y a encore des problèmes entre la
relation gendarme police même si c'est
amélioré ça reste quand même imparfait
donc ils vont dans toutes les failles
qui peuvent repérer et bon je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails on aurait pas
le temps mais la drogue ensuite sur
certaines grosses cités à Marseille les
plus connu mais c'est pas les seuls ça
va être la Castellane ça va être Herbel
ça va être la buusterine ça va
être campagne l'évêque actuellement il y
a la paternelle et voilà et puis tout
cassé 10 cité je suis pas sûr même
qu'elles y soient et ces cités là après
vont vont avoir des vont vont faire à la
fois des ventes au détail et en même
temps se migrossissent pour les autres
et à chaque fois il y a pas de relation
de hiérarchie c'est de l'indépendance
pourquoi ils font ça parce que la
gestion de terrain
payer des gens sur le terrain c'est
quelque chose de compliqué qui prend du
temps il y a beaucoup de trahison ça
coûte beaucoup d'argent et si on paye
bien les gens parce qu' il y a quelque
chose de complètement faux qui se répète
tout le temps c'est que les jeunes
seraient bien payés je peux vous assurer
que c'est totalement farfelu si on paye
bien les les les les jeunes ben ils
deviennent les concurrents donc c'est un
souci en fait ils font tout au contraire
et c'est le principal message que je
veux faire passer ce soir que ce qui
tient un réseau de stup aujourd'hui
c'est la dette le but principal et quasi
unique est d'endetter les jeunes qui
vont être les petites
mains